the agenda is set i'm break off in
berlin it's time to talk
nsa leaker edward snowden has political
fans in germany does berlin dare to
offer him a new home
the violence that was turkey this summer
will peace finally come by putting
turkey in the eu
and syria's civil war now home to polio
a plea to all sides let the doctors save
your children
welcome to the show everyone i've
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my first
guest has dodged bombs in a cave in a
makeshift clinic in syria all to help
that country's wounded i'm happy to
welcome back to the show dr tonkrat
strobe he's head of the german division
of doctors without borders
concrete you just finished another visit
to the area and you're bringing back
some sobering news from the medical
front we're going to hear from you a
little bit later on in the show
my second guest says europe must renew
its embrace of turkey even if it never
lets turkey join the eu i'm happy to
welcome to the show dilek kerbon she is
one of germany's leading turkey analysts
based here in berlin at the german
institute for international and security
affairs dee like it's good to have you
on the show
and my next guest is one of the leading
voices in the campaign to bring edward
snowden to germany i'm happy to welcome
to the show stefan liebish he is a
member of the left party he's a member
of the parliament here in berlin and
he's also the spokesman for
transatlantic relations for the left
party stefan good to have you on the
show will there be any relations to
speak up with the u.s if you bring
edward snowden to germany i think so and
i think it should be like this because
that we are partners and friends
doesn't mean that we have to accept
everything
if you would invite brent a friend to
your home and he would sneak around the
corners and would read your emails would
it be a good answer as a friend
to say nothing to ignore him or would it
better to tell him and this well i'd
probably confront him and i think a lot
of people are are wondering why isn't
there more confrontation directly from
berlin to washington why do you need to
go through russia
and use edward snowden let me ask
everybody here at the table are you
shocked at the support that edward
snowden is getting
what do you say
no actually i'm not um well i mean i
don't know germany that well obviously
but i think in any um
when i think about the world at large
i'm not surprised at the support he's
getting because i think there's a
concern in every country
about
the states going too far and the
intelligence of agencies going too far
state surveillance going too far into
people's privacy
privacy um and i think this is um but
yeah i'm not surprised yeah i'm
surprised talking what do you say
no i'm i'm concerned because as a
medical organization we deal with sort
of delicate information and we we
basically have to rethink our strategy
to transfer all those information and
working all over the world um we cannot
sort of trust the
email system even even sort of the
blackberries they are not safe anymore
yeah so that uh and and i'm grateful
that there is someone who who uncovers
how unsafe it is to use those means
steven would you say that edward snowden
is a hero
that is not the question if he is a hero
or if he is not i think he did the right
thing
he said to us the truth while the u.s
government lied to us it is absurd that
a partnership
government would monitor the cell phone
of our government we shouldn't accept it
and it is absurd too that the chiefs of
intelligence services right now are
negotiating a no spy uh treaty because
they asked they are spies all right i
want to pick up that in a second but you
say he's not a hero yeah but you're you
know you want him to come to germany you
want to give him asylum yeah because
don't you give asylum protection to
people who have done heroic deeds if you
look at our law of residence then our
government is allowed to
protect the political interests of our
country and if there is a
man like edward snowden who did this
then we should grant him asylum yes okay
i mean interesting you know hearing that
he could be one of germany's best
friends right now the
u.s position is clear on edward snowden
he remains high on the public enemy list
the white house and top congressional
lawmakers have rejected any talk of
clemency for the fugitive nsa leaker
snowden says he would like to testify
before congress about what he knows but
if he can't go home maybe he'll find a
new home right here there are political
parties maneuvering as we speak to force
the german government chancellor angela
merkel included to grant snowden asylum
once snowden is here his fans contend
he'll be able to tell all now does this
really make sense is snowden
that important to germany
in germany the u.s spying scandal took
on a new dimension with claims that
washington had tapped chancellor angela
merkel's cell phone
the focus is now on the man behind the
revelations former nsa intelligence
contractor edward snowden a german
opposition politician met him last week
in moscow snowden said he'd like to
provide the german government with more
details but he fears coming to germany
could mean he'd be handed over to the
u.s
there are now growing calls in germany
to grant snowden asylum so he can travel
to berlin and share what he knows
would that spell the end of friendly
relations between the u.s and germany
stefan are you about to destroy the
transatlantic relationship
no i
don't want to do this and i think no one
in the german bundestag would do it but
friendship and partnership doesn't mean
to ignore such things i think as friends
we have to say there is a red line and
you have crossed this red line you
cannot spy at the cell phone of the head
of our government and you cannot spy
hundreds of thousands of emails of the
german citizens we cannot accept do you
trust edward snowden more than
the secretary of state of the u.s
to be honest in this case yes but to be
sure
how can you talk about then a
relationship of trust and you can say
you trust a 30-year-old
contractor for the nsa to tell you the
truth more than you do the white house
or the state department because we
did have the facts on the table i don't
think that the guardian or
very
famous newspapers in the world would lie
they look at the papers and i think the
papers are true and i have to fear that
the us government did lie to us and we
cannot accept it and so we want to
invite edward snowden to us have a
special meeting ask him and then we will
know more how do you know what edward
snowden
would tell you is the truth he's got the
documents that's one thing but he also
says he's seen and heard things yeah
aren't you being judged and jury by
saying you believe him enough to give
him asylum for that we need such an
parliamentary inquiry and we will have a
special meeting next week from our
parliament for especially this case and
in the u.s you have parliamentary
inquiries in germany we will have it too
and then we will ask questions and then
we will make decisions but it is not a
good way
don't you have the chance to ask why
don't you just ask him in russia why
don't you fly to moscow like the green
politician strobella did and ask him i
think this is the second best way i
think
isn't it isn't it much safer to do that
he's in russia where he has asylum you
can go there you can get the information
from him why not do that wouldn't it be
terrible to be safer in russia than in
germany and i think germany is a
democratic state we have civil rights
what's what is the point here is
germany's sovereignty and security the
point or is the security of edward
snowden the point
why is his welfare any concern of yours
stefan he's an american citizen he would
prefer to come to germany and he has a
chance to come to germany and even if
you look at the
extradition treaty between the united
states and germany we have to check the
chance to have him safe here we
shouldn't
have extradition to the united states
because it is in our essential interests
and this is a part of this treaty we can
have him safe here and we have to say to
our u.s american friends we will but why
i'm still let me ask you again why not
interrogate him why not question him
in moscow
because we are the parliament of germany
and not a tourist office we have to be
here we make our decisions here and we
invite witnesses to germany and we would
be very happy to have him here a
majority
the polls that i've been reading the
last couple of days show that a majority
of germans do not want asylum granted to
snowden
is stefan on the wrong side here
i mean i think there are two issues here
one is
him you know snowden whether he should
be given asylum or not and the other is
you know the german governments and
societies wish to know the truth at the
when you look at snowden as an
individual you know under international
law anybody who has a well-founded
persecution fear of persecution on
various grounds is entitled to seek
asylum and looks like this person has
could arguably be um well well founded
fear of persecution well he could be
prosecuted because he
he broke the law in the united states
prosecuted i mean when you look at you
know the example i mean post 9 11
policies in in the us
are very concerned this concern
concerning um in terms of human rights
violations look at guantanamo bay look
at what happened
to the soldier
um what was his name um who had
manny
i'm talking about edward snowden though
he was a contractor with the nsa
he was you know he had to take an oath
that he would not
leak any information but he did that
anyway so he broke the law it's a
federal law now is it in germany's
interest to say
that federal law and the enforcement of
that
law is not
in germany's interest
well i think they have to sort of
balance what is what is of greater value
the the truth he's speaking out here or
a law he may have broken somewhere and
so i think that's have to be balanced
out by the politicians um
um i think sort of the value he can
bring in by telling the truth and all
his knowledge um is of great value so
you want him to come
well personally i mean i i would leave
that up to the politicians here but you
got a politician
yeah right so ask him
sort of i think we should make use of
his intelligence and knowledge and bring
that to the public i mean angela merkel
has said that she does not want asylum
to be given to him and that the
relationship with the united states is
paramount to any decision that is made
in the wake of this scandal
you're not on the same page with her no
i
disagree uh we are a sovereign state and
i think it is important uh to protect
the interests of our citizens and i
cannot cannot accept a master violence
about the emails and facebook and
twitter dates and how how are german
citizens going to be more secure and
safer
if you have edward snowden come
and
speak on german soil i'm trying to see
the connection here how are we in berlin
going to be safer
we need to know the facts what does the
nsa
know and with these facts we can debate
with our u.s american friends
what practices we will accept and what
practices we will not accept and i think
before we can do do this we need the
facts um how likely do you think it is
that he's going to get asylum are you
going to try to force a vote in the
bundestag in the parliament we will we
will have a meeting next week we will
make this proposal and i have heard from
the green party that they will agree
with us and there are a lot of people in
the social democratic party too so we
could have the majority
do you have enough votes so you're
stefan
we have
three of the four groups in the german
bundestag who would agree but the
problem is that one group is negotiating
with the christian democrats right now
so i'm not sure what they will do okay
and that's the spd right all right so
it's it's less likely now as as these
coalition negotiations but you know
that's domestic politics um i mean it
looks like you're not going to get this
vote
so what
then
does snowden become for you if you can't
bring him to germany
the second best option would be that he
would ask him as a witness in his
present home in russia i don't like this
option but but you would do it i would
do it okay
um
i mean i i think i think probably most
germans agree with you at least the
polls tell us that that's probably what
most germans would like to see happen
what about relations with the united
states
do you trust the united states you say
our american friends
to be honest i think i don't think that
estates are friends or governments are
friends they have to work in the
interests of their people but we have a
good and stable relationship and
partnership and we should go on with it
but it is no longer a time that we are a
colony or something like that we are a
sovereign state and so sometimes we have
to say no
okay but
is snowden for your party though chef
i'm trying to get to the core of this is
this um a tool for your party
to rub this scandal in washington's face
no
sharden freud is the german no no no i
would be very happy if we uh would not
discuss this topic and to be honest uh i
i knew that uh intelligence services
doing some things which are very strange
but that they are monitoring the cell
phone of the chancellor of germany i i
wouldn't believe it okay there's that
does i mean you're a politician you're a
member of parliament does germany
monitor the cell phones of let's say the
french president i don't know i hope not
but the problem is not in this case you
are right this problem is not a u.s
american problem this is an intelligent
service problem okay
have you considered pulling the heads of
german intelligence
agencies bringing them into parliament
and asking them questions about how they
dropped the ball aren't they supposed to
be protecting german we we have a lot of
problems with our intelligence services
we did have a special committee in the
last legislation about the so-called nsu
scandal they didn't see your nazi
killings you are right and and so i'm
very unhappy unhappy with our
intelligence service so i don't uh would
defend them you would not defend them so
we've got a lot of factors here a lot of
balls we're juggling right here but um
tonka let me ask you as a german do you
feel like your security
agencies here in germany have they let
you down
well um
i mean as i said earlier i think i think
the safest thing today to communicate uh
sort of uh
um sensitive issues is by meeting in a
in a park and talk directly so
everything that goes across border is is
difficult um
and um even in a park you can still be
right right
yeah 21st century yeah no i sort of i
think it is the the good thing we
learned over the last couple of months
is that um
you if you have sort of uh confidential
issues and there's doctors and a medical
organization we have to deal with that
we have to completely rethink our whole
strategy how to how we deal with that
and and honestly i don't trust any any
sort of secret service because they of
course have their own agenda to to um
and they're not i mean they have to
protect the the politicians the
government more than than probably the
society itself
is germany giving america um a raw deal
here forgetting about what happened
after 911 and the panic that the united
states had the fact that they stopped
all restraints on intelligence gathering
to find out what was behind the 911 plot
isn't it understandable that a country
would maybe in some instances
eavesdrop on the chancellor's phone
but but there are red lines yes it is it
is the reaction that you're calling for
stefan the reaction yeah is it
proportional to what happened
in this buying scandal aren't you
overreacting no i think it is
proportional and i think what they did
is unproportional we are not talking
about north korea or china we are
talking about partners and friends in
some way
in this case you cannot go so far i mean
before we move on i just want to read
something that um
was in their spiegel um it's the
commentary from the u.s
if europeans want to salvage the
transatlantic relationship they must
accept that they will have to do so
without an official public apology
the americans particularly in washington
they are really perturbed with the
germans they argue that their quarrels
and disappointments with past german
policies never chipped away at their
fundamental trust in berlin why are the
germans so willing so quickly to give up
trust in
the americans
i think it is not our fault we did
inspire the cell phone of barack obama
uh the nsa did it to angela merkel that
we know of stefan
german citizens and so i think it is the
right thing okay i don't need apologies
apologies are not important for me i
think we should end this practice okay
last question move on if germany has the
ability to tap barack obama's telephone
should it do it no
do you think it has happened
i don't know and i hope not all right
okay let's move on it was just a few
months ago when i put turkey's crackdown
on dissent and free speech on the agenda
right here you may remember the
consensus this past summer on this
program was that turkey's march towards
a liberal democracy in the mold of the
eu had been significantly stalled tear
gas water cannons all aimed at peaceful
protesters in an istanbul park
in june turkey seemed more foreign to
europe than it has in a long time
well that's the past the summer the
protests the violence are over and the
european union is restarting membership
talks with turkey but which turkey
is europe talking to
this week talks on turkey joining the eu
resumed after a break of more than three
years
they were initially scheduled for june
but they were put on hold after
anti-government protests in turkey led
to a violent police crackdown
germany headed the countries demanding a
delay to the eu membership talks
now the thinking is the talks might
counter authoritarian moves by the
turkish government and encourage reforms
there's little hope the talks will get
anywhere fast germany is just one of the
eu countries opposed to turkey ever
being granted full eu membership
but other european countries are eager
to bring the booming turkish economy
into the fold
with the memories of violence still
fresh is this the right time to be
rewarding turkey
what do you say to that dude like is
this the right time to reward turkey
with ascension talks considering what
happened in june
i mean first i think this one we should
not see this as rewarding turkey
because accession negotiations um with
turkey as with any other candidate
country have a certain
natural flow of their own there are two
critical decisions in this process one
is the eu's decision to open accession
negotiations with a candidate country
and the other is the eu's decision to
give full
membership
the first one has already been given by
the eu back in 2004 and accession
negotiations have started in 2005.
the other
is
nowhere inside it's not going to happen
in the next 10 20 years or so probably
now where we were
where turkey and eu were was just in
between somewhere in between these two
points actually not even between these
two points there are 35 chapters that
canada countries and the eu negotiate in
this process it is a long process with
turkey
since 2005
only 13 have been opened and only one of
which have been provisionally closed so
this how not available
is the eu i mean to answer your question
first i understand what you're saying it
is not it's it certainly is far from a
candidate country far from um you know
being um showing the responsibility of a
candidate country in terms of protection
of human rights democracy etc
but that's why the accession
negotiations are so key but isn't the eu
doing turkey a favor then we're back to
this word rewarding they're doing ankara
a favor by keeping these talks alive no
they are i think the understanding in
the eu is that they actually are by ex
by opening another chapter they are
giving support to civil society in
turkey that's how the eu is looking at
this now and i think that's a good way
of looking at if the talks had been
going on in the summer do you think the
crackdown would have happened the crack
no i don't think so and actually the
protests might have not been so big also
because what has
led so many thousands of people into the
streets was this sort of sense of
unrepresentation being excluded by the
turkish government not being heard being
left alone being left alone and and not
having any hope now if turkey
if we were three you know where we were
three years ago where you know accession
negotiations were going on there was
there were reforms there was a hope
there was um you know a site sort of
there was a future inside
then people the people in the position
had less reason to really go on the
streets all right let's turn the finger
then and point it back at us stefan has
europe have the germans let the turks
down
no and we shouldn't do it in the future
but
let me say one thing first we have an
internal problem here in germany in the
german bundestag because our ruling
christian democrats are against a
membership of turkey in the eu and the
three other parties the green parties
social democrats and our party are in
favor of it but nevertheless after
the taksim square thing
stefan how do you explain that here you
are praising the ideals that edward
snowden stands for yeah and if you go go
back in time to june and go to istanbul
you had a government that was cracking
down on peaceful demonstrators using
tear gas and water cannons now why
should you be willing to talk
with ankara if they behave this way
they're behaving the same way you say
the nsa is behaving yeah and because of
that i think this is not a good signal
to open a new chapter right now what we
would ask for is a new signals for civil
rights uh for religion freedom
for freedom of uh speaking in turkey and
that's what we not got in the last month
and weeks and so i think it is not a
good idea to open a new chapter right
now but it is a different story from
angela merkel's christian democrats they
don't want to have turkey in the eu we
want but we need a little more time and
more discussions in turkey the minister
for european union affairs in turkey iga
manbagis
said
that his country has to accept that its
long-cherished goal of joining the eu
will end in disappointment he says i
think in the long run turkey will end up
like norway
what's wrong with that
well it's
the norwegians are happy yes but turkey
is not like norway and that's not going
to happen what he means is we will be
like norway our economy is doing so well
and our institutions are there we
actually don't need the eu just like
norway does but turkey is not like
norway our economy is not as strong as
norway and our institutions are not um a
strong democracy we don't have a
democracy yet in the sub-century
is that the fear that without being
integrated in the eu that
the political establishment of turkey
and here we are with trust again
cannot be trusted to take turkey towards
a liberal democracy
yeah
i mean that's a bit that's a big
indictment that you're saying here
you're saying not only erdogan but the
entire political establishment of turkey
cannot be trusted to act in the
interests of its people
well let me not use the word trusted but
the eu process is very key for
democratization in turkey i mean when
you look back history
turkey's
turkey has always been
a europeanization process this this um
project it has always been a project and
that has always what pushed country
towards reform but this should not be
misunderstood that if there was no eu
there wouldn't be any internal demand
for democracy in turkey no that's not
the case at all there is a strong civil
society in turkey that's getting
stronger and um and louder in a way and
there is there is a real demand on the
part of many people in turkey for
democracy but we have a very strong
state tradition which has always been
authoritarian there is really not an
established culture of democracy in
turkey but things are changing what
about the last 80 years though what
about the legacy of ataturk well that
was not democracy really
but it was it was a secularized state
sure
that um europe has always
praised and lauded well that depends
also on how you define secularism um you
know we have the dianeta institution the
institute of religious affairs a huge
bureaucracy employing
thousands of people with a very big
budget which is funded by the government
on religious affairs so
leaving that aside i mean what extent
turkey secular really i think is a
question mark
but then when you look at democracy i
mean turkey was okay arguably a secular
country but not a democracy we have
three military coup d'etats actually
more military interventions
the majority has never really been
represented the much devout muslim
majority has never been given a voice in
turkey until 10 years ago or so tango
you've spent time obviously in turkey
dealing with the syrian crisis is turkey
a part of europe is it europe did you
feel like you were in europe when you
were on the border between syria and
turkey
well sort of to give you two example how
how i see that turkey is really striving
in the last years and one was two years
ago when i was in somalia actually the
sort of the first ships coming into
mogadishu port to to give aid to
mogadishu and and somalia were from
turkish government
sort of
that was a very encouraging thing when
all the the other europeans were too
scared even to come into the waters of
somalia and um last year in syria or
until very recently um the turkish
government made very clear that um they
can look after the syrian refugees in
turkey themselves they don't need
international help they don't need
international organizations of course we
have a different stake here but it
clearly shows that the turkish
government is trying to find another
another stronger role in the world and
but what about for the turkish people
though i mean i'm concerned about what
happens inside you know there are more
journalists in prison in turkey than in
china
um
minorities you know they can keep
wishing all day if they want their
rights to be protected gays and lesbians
for example try to go build a church
in turkey
um
the question again
when you see the reality on the ground
um is aren't these recession talks um
aren't they misplaced the timing is
wrong right erdogan and his government
they have not done their homework now
the timing is not it's actually very
right i mean first of all i would um you
know
kindly disagree because that's exactly
what accession negotiations are for to
help candidate countries to improve
democracy and human rights opening a new
chapter doesn't mean taking turkey into
membership
the the whole purpose of accession
negotiations is actually to give
homework for the eu to give in a way
homework to kind of the countries and to
actually keep it under monitoring had
the chapters on
justice and
security on fundamental rights been
opened
a couple of years ago i don't think we
would have been here now because there
would have been a continuous dialogue
between the eu and turkey and there will
be monitoring
but to come to your question briefly
that we have to move on it wouldn't be
rewarding um the turkish government it
would be giving support to civil society
in turkey okay do you think in your
lifetime
turkey will become a member of the eu
no but in my lifetime the eu may not
also
continue to exist god okay that's
another story yeah and stefan may be out
of a job then all right let's move on if
turkey
does not seem to be preoccupied with
europe right now it has good reason its
border with syria is where the action is
action that ankara wishes would also
become part of the past well no such
luck the syrian civil war rages on
despite damascus giving up its chemical
weapons the humanitarian crisis is worse
than ever for the first time since 1999
children are coming down with polio now
you have to remember syria before this
war was the poster child of vaccination
efforts in the middle east every child
in syria was vaccinated against polio
and other diseases before the conflict
began more than two years of fighting
have exposed syria's children to
unspeakable horrors including diseases
that have no place
in the 21st century
fighting in syria continues with no end
in sight
since 2011 the civil war has killed
around 115 000 people millions more have
fled the country
it's not just bombs and bullets that are
threatening people's lives the world
health organization has now confirmed an
outbreak of polio
it's the first in syria in 14 years
the syrian government blames foreign
jihadists for bringing the virus into
the country
but organizing immunization for all of
syria's children is almost impossible in
the war-torn country
yeah the children are the victims every
day you see that don't you i mean you
just got back
you were on the show a year ago you had
just gotten back
the situation's gotten worse
it certainly does
this year i was in northern iraq and we
had a medical tent right at the border
where we saw more than 800 patients over
the course of four weeks and that was
the only window when that border was
open more than 60 000 syrian refugees
crossed from syria into iraq
the biggest actually the biggest output
of refugees out of syria in the entire
crisis so far
we have seen um more than sort of a
fifth of these
refugees where young children under five
and all of them had terrible stories to
tell and vaccination is one of them
measle vaccination polio vaccination but
also pregnant women we had mothers
coming over to the border who just gave
birth a day ago and
said well they had waited in syria for
the baby to be born and then the next
day they made it over to the border
to feel to feel safe to have access to
health care but
that is the biggest problem we see in
syria a completely collapsing health
health system a health system that's
collapsing and
the world the international community
the politicians they're concerned about
chemical weapons
um
isn't that concern misplaced
as a doctor
as a doctor very clearly what we see is
yes they are the war wounded and here we
talk about tens of thousands of people
being war wounded and not having access
to care we know that people who get a
serious war wound need to be treated
within an hour that is impossible for a
lot of people in syria at the moment
we also concerned of course of the
vulnerable people young children
sort of pregnant mothers older people
but also chronic patients we see that at
the moment probably more people died in
syria because of untreated chronic
diseases than from war wounds we you
know we've brought you here today we put
you at the table here you've got a
member of the german parliament with you
i mean obviously that's where the purse
strings are
what tell stefan what to do doctors
without borders what do you need from
governments in europe now
you know stefan very clear it is
completely frustrating for us to see the
lack of political will to solve that
crisis the lack also of the political
actors to support the people yeah and we
and if you say well it is too dangerous
to work in syria you can say yes but on
the other hand we have six clinics at
the moment working in syria it is
possible under extremely difficult
conditions here there are no reasons
there are no apologies for me not to
support the refugees in the surrounding
countries and we know from lebanon more
than 30 percent of the population in
lebanon are syrian refugees at the
moment and the the complete country is
overburdened the the lebanon people have
no access to healthcare anymore because
the hospitals are overcrowded here and
the wealth community is is completely
fading politically no it does not stefan
i would disagree i think the world
community is caring about this uh
terrible civil war but the key to solve
the problems is in the u.n security
council and uh yeah to be clear to me
yeah it is right we we need we need a
decision by the your security council we
need an agreement with with russia and
china and that is a problem but you're
not going to get that
we did get this in the question of
chemical weapons
it is less but it was important
we have been trying we've been trying
let me read you a press release from
doctors without borders
syrian people are now presented with the
absurd situation of chemical weapons
inspectors driving freely through areas
in desperate need while ambulances and
food and drug supplies organized by
humanitarian organizations are blocked
the priorities are completely screwed up
and
they're that way because of what the
international community has done what
politicians
are doing but
if you uh would agree that we have an
international rule of law then we have
to discuss with the
united nations and their security
council but there is one thing what we
can do independently we can do
grant more asylum to syrian refugees
here in germany we have only a few five
thousand also so i think we should do
more on this i think we should give more
money to help them help the people in
the countries around syria that's what
we can do independently and that's what
we should do okay you are definitely a
fan of asylum but bringing
some families to germany is not going to
change what's happening on the ground
but what would you
what would your answer be we had a
discussion about in military
intervention
if you think about this and if you think
about the end let's talk about this
would be worse than before then it
wouldn't be an answer i'm concerned
right now about getting help to the
children to the the women the sick
people uh the political solution can
come later but who
who's in the way who's preventing
vaccinations for example concrete no i
mean people tell me told me and and i
asked them um sort of and i've spoken to
hundreds of student refugees in the last
two years
they're blocked that they try to stay in
syria they don't want to come to germany
they even if they are in the neighboring
country their number one goal their
number one wish is to go back to syria
yeah so this whole slim seeker um
discussion even so i agree with you it's
it's a shame in germany that that we
after a month of debate agreed five
thousand yeah but that is not the
solution the solution has to be in syria
and in the neighboring neighboring
country and the people are blocked in
syria they they they faced i've spoken
to a family um prior to when they made
it to us they they left after they have
moved inside syria six times six times
they tried to find a safe place then
their home was bombed again then when
they finally decided to flee
they came to a roadblock they were
captured for two days then released then
they illegally crossed the border to
turkey because inside turkey it's easier
at the moment to move than inside syria
because of all the roadblocks
they secretly sort of move back into
syria and then from syria across into
iraq and that's when they came to our
tent completely sick people are
completely sort of needed shocked for
for all what they have gone through and
they say there is no way to find health
and and security in syria anymore you've
got you have some video that you took
also right of what you saw in syria with
refugees right tell me a little bit
about that
yeah um i mean this this place where we
put up our medical tent at the border we
could look through a valley and you can
see that at our homepage um we could
look down and it's sort of a five
kilometer no man's land it was desert
like it was more than 50 degrees hot so
people had to walk through that every
single day to make it over to to iraq so
of course only those who were basically
healthy could manage to come
and those people were exhausted people
were chronically sick people sort of
unbuttoned their shirts saying well i
had cardiac surgery in syria and i need
it again that's why i came here um and i
had to tell them well sorry for you but
even northern iraq the health facilities
are not good enough to do this um the
polio outbreak though i i don't want us
to forget that in in all of this um is
it as simple as getting the vaccinations
to the children
i mean it is actually a simple solution
isn't it i mean msf doctors with our
borders we vaccinated so far 80 000
children for for measles and polio of
course that's not enough at all and we
don't have access to to everywhere there
is no agency at the moment in syria
neither the public health system nor
international un or icrc or doctors with
reporters who have access to all the
children so vaccination alone you have
to apply it to the children and that's
not working what are doctors telling you
about all of these foreign jihadists
that are going into syria now
we get reports that they're actually
blocking access
if anyone has humanitarian goods they're
blocking it
are you hearing that did you hear that
did you see that while you were there
well the the the problem in syria at the
moment is it becomes more and more
complex the the conflict there are more
and more stakeholders so for us talking
to all the stakeholders it becomes more
and more difficult to make any security
arrangement with all the parties on the
ground and yes
there is sort of the government troops
there's the opposition troops there's
now all those religious groups what
about these jihadists bringing in
diseases with them coming from pakistan
afghanistan coming into syria where
conditions are abysmal
outsiders are actually a threat to the
health of
the
syrians right now aren't they well it is
maybe one component i wouldn't
exaggerate that one the biggest problem
we see is that syrians don't have health
access in their country more than the
majority of hospitals are either damaged
or destroyed what about assad before
before we wrap up is the assad regime
are they showing a willingness now
though to at least help the children
well we don't see that we see that
entire areas in the countries are
isolated blocked people are starving
people are dying from hunger and and
this is still in a sort of warm warm
time of the year it's getting colder
it's getting minus minus freezing
temperatures soon and people are not
able to to live in in places where they
have no heating no electricity no
running water anymore when are you going
back
well um usually i'm i'm able to do it
once a year so uh probably again next
year and are doctors without borders
anticipating that all of next year
they're going to be needed in syria they
see no end to this do they well i've all
the people i've asked or the syrians
i've asked they are very desperate they
don't see any help they don't see any
hope that the conflict will end soon
yeah well um
yeah we hope we can have you on the show
again next year and that the report can
be better and we certainly hope that the
children can get the vaccinations they
need that's going to wrap up this
edition of agenda with brent goff
remember you can contact me anytime with
your thoughts on the show you can find
me on facebook you can tweet me at
brentgoff tv or you can email me you see
the address on the screen if you want to
watch the show again go to dw's website
or watch us on
youtube i'm brent goff in berlin join me
next time when i set the agenda
you